les canulars médiatiques sont aussi
vieux que la presse elle-même mais
l'effet démultiplicateur des réseaux
sociaux créent aujourd'hui des
répercussions sans équivalent dans
l'histoire
mathieu bonsoir c'est derrière les
internautes des millions d'entre eux et
les grands médias se sont fait prendre
justement la semaine dernière absolument
avec cette vidéo c'est rien de
mirobolant qui fait vraiment le tour du
web est un canular est une équipe
norvégienne qui a tourné sa à malte
l'été dernier et on a su quelques jours
après en fait c'est le réalisateur qui
s'est rétractée qui a d'écouté on
voulait susciter une conversation autour
de la présence des enfants dans les
zones de conflit ça n'a pas fonctionné
autre canular mais ça c'est une jeune
femme visiblement éméché qui se
promènent à hollywood et qui ce fait
propose xd avance par des hommes
les hommes qui se sont fait filmer dans
cette vidéo la sont sorties dans les
médias d'écouté nous on ne peut
présenter cela comme étant une vidéo
confuse vous faisait croire que c'était
la réalité cette vidéo humoristique donc
encore d'un canular mais qui a enflammé
la la la la ligne 2 de l'aller les
médias sociaux
bon c'est pas nouveau cependant parce
que ça fait quand même quelques temps
très triste on a déjà connu ça on a déjà
connu ça dans les années 30
écoutez bien c'est en 1938 ce qu'on veut
entendre et bien une armée qui viennent
mars
on a cru à sa en 1938 c'était le grand
réalisateur orson welles bien évidemment
plus près de nous à la veille de la
première guerre mondiale c'est le nonce
vous vous en souvenez vous étiez ici
radio canada cette fameuse infirmières
la première guerre du golfe lui ces
fameuses infirmières qu un siège qu'on
présentait comme une infirmière qui
disait que les soldats de saddam hussein
était rentré dans les hôpitaux sortait
les enfants des incubateurs tirer sur
les incubateurs mais c'était la fille de
l'ambassadeur koweïtien et ça avait été
mise en scène par une agence de
relations publiques proche du parti
républicain lorrain faut pas toujours
croire ce qu'on voit bon alors dans le
contexte des réseaux sociaux par contre
ça change parce que ça existe
mais là c'est comme vous disiez que
c'est vraiment un accélérateur très
grand accélérateur les médias sociaux
sont avides d'image sont avides de
sensations les internautes aussi veulent
être les premiers à mettre en ligne des
choses donc on se dépêche de retweeter
de mettre en ligne ses vidéos là quand
même son imposture de la provenance les
images aussi que son granuleuse ben ça
arrange les la tricherie peut-être un
peu plus facile à faire
on se rappelle en 2012 il y avait bien
eu un très bon canular ce cas des
étudiants du centre nad qui avait mis en
scène un aigle qui s'y posent les mêmes
mais chercher un enfant au mont royal
ville monde s'était fait prendre moi
c'est différent mais si on avait attendu
quand on attend quelques heures les
médias sociaux aussi peuvent être un
frais l'heure à la mise en ligne de
mauvaises informations parce qu'ils
avaient des spécialistes qui avaient des
écoutes et on n'est pas sûr l'ombre du
de l'inde le legs est pas très bien fait
donc on n'y pas certaines la provenance
de ça donc ce on attend un peu
généralement on va pouvoir séparer le
bon grain de l'ivraie
donc en fait ya des principes qui
changent pas les 5 w qui quoi où comment
pourquoi les grands médias sont garants
de ça donc il faut toujours faire
attention prendre le temps aussi devoir
de vérifier la provenance de ces vidéos
la con mais qu'on met en ligne mais ça
empêche pas à contrarier aussi de voir
encore aujourd'hui des gens qui croient
qu'il ya aucun avion qui est entré dans
le dans le world trade center lors du 11
septembre
donc il ya des gens qui mentent ça
existe mais vive le journaliste
traditionnelle alors après les émeutes
des jeunes et criaient des principes en
tout cas j'espère que ça c'est sûr merci
beaucoup de plaisir